so usually having a reputation for being
extremely good at a video game when it
comes to streaming your eSports it's a
good thing we see it all the time right
popular pub stars making the jump to
pros and building a career off of that
reputation but things don't always work
out that way you could be extremely good
at a game but despite all of that the
only thing people want to do is ruin
your entire career that's exactly what's
happening with a streamer called Argo so
Before we jump into this one by
subscribing to the channel liking the
video and leaving a comment you've
really helped us understand what you
want to see more of so keep it coming
and also if you have a news tip for us
well we have a tips email so send them
over there
now back to the story so this is our guy
he's an insanely talented 4600 SR Hanzo
main who frequently ranks in the top 500
and GM for competitive soloqueue in
overwatch and he constantly deals with
random people trying to ruin his game on
purpose they int him they trying to get
him kicked they report him they do
everything they can to D rank this guy
into oblivion now obviously in ting or
intentionally throwing is where your
teammates purposely tried to lose the
game just so you specifically can't win
no no no cannon every poke the sleek boy
for me oh yeah yeah sure I don't like
yeah yeah now in the case of argA this
isn't just a few people in ting and
throwing his game this is an organized
attack on him specifically like at this
point there's entire discord servers
where people pay other players to
intentionally D rank and [ __ ] with agro
and by the way he's one of many players
and streamers who appear on these weird
in ting hit lists I've gotten pictures
from from five different discards like
people leaking the leaking the stuff and
like like people come up to me almost
daily in the DMS to tell me oh these
people were
or like talking about how they threw all
their games today so why the hell do
people hate this dude so much well to
explain that we just have to rewind a
little bit
so after dealing with long bouts of
depression and burnout that caused argA
to drop out of university he found that
he had a lot of time on his hands I felt
like I was a huge failure and like if
there's nothing more left for me and the
reason why I never started dreaming was
because I felt like people would just
laugh at me and think I'm stupid
it's just like most people in real life
so I was like well since I am a failure
I'm stupid and all that stuff maybe I
should just dream and let everyone laugh
at me and while he jumped into streaming
with this like it couldn't get any worse
mentality he was surprised to find that
people were actually really positive
when he started streaming now the
trouble started with the character that
he mains hanzo and escalated after he
developed a reputation for being an
[ __ ] when dealing with other
aggressive players people hated to play
with him so and people hated to play
against hand so if anyone would like
flame at me or blame me for the loss and
stuff when obviously it was not my fault
like it but they were just blaming me
since I was playing the worst hero so I
would mediate just retaliate and like I
told you that I took it very personally
despite being extremely good with Hanzo
teammates and opponents made fun of them
for using a character that was
considered a bit of a meme and instead
of ignoring the stupid comments Argo
would consistently fight back once
people realized that they continued
flaming him partly because it was funny
to watch him flip out but also because
they just didn't like him it's kind of
like a cycle like let's say there's a
person in my in my match and then I piss
him off and like he might say that I may
go he stick so then I will act even more
egoistic just to piss him off and then
he's gonna go to his friends with this
story and maybe patented the story a bit
make it even worse when these people get
into my team that he told me about and
they will immediately be hostile towards
me and then I will be hostile back it's
kind of like a cycle that kept expanding
people did everything they could to [ __ ]
with him jumping off the map
reporting him at the beginning of games
even going so far as trying to get his
account suspended and this wasn't a once
in a while thing according to argA this
was a 16 hour a day everyday thing and
those discord servers I mentioned they
are full of conversations with people
talking about the best ways to [ __ ] with
him but there's a reason why agro
wouldn't just ignore the abuse and move
on see throughout his life argA was
bullied pretty severely and he openly
talks about this so he decided that when
he started streaming and playing
overwatch he wasn't gonna take that [ __ ]
anymore I was bullying my whole life at
school I never stood up for myself and
when I started streaming I kind it's
like promised myself that I would never
let anyone make me feel like powerless
and humiliated and thrash like everyone
had always done so I was like I'm just
gonna immediately retaliate now this
type of back-and-forth shit-talking
created a never-ending cycle that
escalated way out of control
now argA found out about these
communities gunning for him after
someone closely associated with one of
them told them about it now if you're
thinking god damn this is ridiculous
I mean it is but a lot of people are
going cluded think that this is a
systemic problem throughout overwatch as
far as argA goes he's had nervous
breakdowns because of all this toxic
attention and it's only after the last
little while that he's managed to shift
his mindset and become a little more
positive on stream I feel like the fact
that people can now see that it's it's
more like a positive thing because it
causes people to talk about me and focus
more on me when they they focus on me so
if this might be the point where I
slowly start getting rid of all these
people and while he says he's gotten
better at controlling his emotions Argus
still have to rip someone a new one if
he thinks they deserve it
dude are you okay it's his first time in
top five fun like 300 right now brother
he [ __ ] had the roast him and when it
comes to blizzard cleaning up the
rampant boosting cheating and bounty
hunting nonsense that argA has to deal
with he doesn't think that there's an
actual solution and when we asked our
guy what he wants his twitch channel to
look like a year from now he's really
focused on making it a safe space for
people who deal with depression social
anxiety and having well just general
issues interacting online I've tried to
mold my stream into this space for
people that got bullied or that are too
anxious to talk in twitch chats that's
the kind of direction I want to take my
stream that's just 100% positive not
making fun of anyone a spark as far what
have [ __ ] that's that's like Kia's new
[ __ ] line is furniture that's Fargo
just my just fires bolts of Buchan
whatever anyway